But you know who's not?
Who's not struggling right now in the United
States, the people at Fox News, well, some
of the shareholders might be losing a little
bit of money because they're struggling to
get advertisers, but the on air personalities,
including the ones that you've really probably
never heard of.
Oh, they're doing great.
And you know why they're doing great because
it turns out, according to a new report from
media matters, shared exclusively with daily
beast.
They're pretty much all shills for the Republican
Party and they're all being paid huge sums
of money to go out and give speeches or make
appearances for Republican candidates and
the Republican Party itself.
This is a fascinating new report because we've
all known for a very long time that Fox News
is a wing of the Republican party, or maybe
the Republican party is a wing of Fox News.
I don't even know which way that goes anymore.
It could be either or.
I'm starting to think Fox News might be the
one calling the shots here, but nonetheless,
here's some of the numbers here as reported
by the daily beast.
Uh, the five cohost, Greg Gutfield earned
more than $36,000 in 2017 speaking at a Washington
Republican Party fundraiser.
Uh, Jeanine Pirro reportedly made 35,000 at
a fundraiser for Pennsylvania Republican gubernatorial
candidate Scott Wagner in 2018.
Fox and friends weekend host Pete Hegseth
made close to 20,000 on a series of speeches
at official fundraisers and Events for Republicans
in 2018.
And then you've got, uh, Laura Ingram, who,
you know, very hate filled woman.
Uh, she only got paid $12,500 in 2016 for
an event addressing the Sangamon County Republican
Central Committee.
So I think Laura Ingram probably needs a better,
uh, handler because everybody else is making
30, $35,000.
You're getting like 12 grand and you're speaking
at
a Republican, you k
would fire these people.
Networks have rules in place that say, you
can't go out there and be a shill for any
particular political party.
You can't speak at their events.
You can't give them money.
Keith Olbermann got suspended from Msnbc for
that in 2010 so they at least try to pretend
that they're not partisan.
Fox News, they don't care.
You want to go be with Trump on stage?
Go for it.
You want to give money, get money by speaking
on behalf of Republican candidates, do your
thing.
And that's why Fox News is so toxic and so
dangerous for this country.
I want to thank David Pakman for letting me
sit in, uh, these past two days.
If you want more from me, you can find me
on youtube at youtube.com/the ring of fire.
Follow me on Twitter, Instagram, and Facebook
at fair and balanced.
Thank you very much for watching.
See you next time.
I've got to tease
the bonus show.
I'm so sorry.